Kerry Lake
said while speaking to the Log Cabin
Republicans that Trump is more amazing
than her own husband have you ever seen
someone suck up to this degree
look at this clip it's starting to be
painful the degree to which Carrie lake
is I think auditioning to be Donald
Trump's vice president
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
20 24. yep
[Music]
her husband can be thanked later but
really the most amazing man in her life
is Trump why is she doing this is it
career advancement she wants to be
Trump's VP or at least Trump's VP
running mate even if they lose maybe
it'll get her some attention sort of
like Sarah Palin had for a while after
losing as John McCain's VP in 28 2008
maybe is it personal gain like she
thinks it would help her with something
about trying to steal the election in
Arizona which he's trying to do or maybe
it will help her continue to grift money
to say stuff like this my husband is
less amazing than Trump and then of
course fear-based politics might also
apply within the Republican party is
there fear of reprisal which is causing
Kerry Lake to feel pressure and to
continue the uh show in which she just
thanks Trump endlessly for everything
and he's so good and he's so amazing I
don't know what the answer is but it's
starting to get pretty cringy and pretty
painful to see but it doesn't look like
it's going to stop anytime soon and any
opportunity she gets she will pray at
the altar she's on her knees for Trump
Jesus I think is the way we would put it
after the break we'll get to other
elements of America Fest we're going to
hear a new analysis from Glenn kirschner
and so many other things glad you're
with us Friday December 23 this Friday
year-end membership special
your first month's payment will be
donated to charity that helps people
directly with cash and doubled matched
dollar for dollar make sure you're on my
mailing list for this Friday sign up at
davidpackman.com
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David Pacman show by getting
your next mattress from Helix sleep and
and you'll get up to 350 off any
mattress plus two free pillows when you
go to Helix sleep.com slash Pacman the
link is down below